h on it up on the board SC the knock that
free kachuck pokes it back to Sanderson here
they go get to Norris Norris back to Sanderson
across the kachu Norris back Sanderson shoot
scores Jake Sanderson power
play goal in Ottawa takes the
lead that's Gos in back to back games for
Jake Sanderson going to go back to the
point kachuck works it over and Josh Norris
who had previously two attempts towards the
net it's a little give and go with Brady
kachuk Sanderson back to the Chuck back
to Sanderson and you've got a screen in front
you see the reaction from Alex to Brink it Mar
wi the face off to Bear cider for to Brink
here's Lin has a look in front bear scores
took 7 seconds for the red rings to strike
into that power play and tie the game at
won this is a an unbelievable set play
pop it back cider down low and then you
continue to cycle it little pop play by
Lin but what a pass by Lin to gosar is
gos Spar is going to shrink down to the
front of the net and you have to elevate
that puck to get it over a stick lens
able to do that over Sanderson stick
and so teams will start the second period five on
five both these teams lost at openers but have
won three straights [Applause] since Cent took
the knock that down in comes lar and drops it back
to BR got level there by kach to bring it back in
the corner with it now L cers and Rond with great
chance there at a point flank save by Coro what a
stop that one Saturday Michigan Ohio State at the
big house at an Harbor and Sunday the rivens play
home again conference s there's a quick chance
oh what a St by corpo on Raymond another great
shot byas corpo game than this one Corpus Salo
identifies gets P get down low Comer tries to
slide it through the seam to Raymond and he's able
to seal that up very quickly if you're going to
have a guy to run one Alex Tangi knows his way
around the power play do he ever he plays it
across and a hard up by strong block by ham that's
a good fight of the Travis HCK strong again send
it back the blood save again in immediate pain and
then this save the Statue of Liberty flash in the
glove Shabbat to CH slaps at that mileno
took it away fromto K scores Fisher Toto
and Detroit grabs the lead thinking
that it's going to go around to his
blocker side comes back short
side what a beautiful pass by
fiser no look knowing that Bano is going to
skate right into that a forehand one timer
and he's able to pop it off the goenda
Salo and Detroit has a a 2-1 lead you
see the reaction now sers reaches up
for that but it skips back to Center
[Applause] ice now bouncing T goes to Greg
with a quick chance and who's on the save on
that this is off to four check strong for check
with Ridley Drake turns that puck over bareno
tries to slide it to him a little Spin and turn
on it but by Walmer s back with Sanderson cross
he goes Norris let Los who say KCK battling for
it b rolls it live back it goes to Norris a cuse
for terceo to return that pass but that was
blocked now Shabbat goes back across in Cher
to shot rebound oh what a chance there teraso hit
the post or kubik rather now teraso turned away
Cher to shot kicked off by hoo as Rings go back
to the man Advantage lots of great chances r on
that power play but Detroit here is Steiner with
it down to Lin her back to cider feeds it across
that's whistle wide by to break it CER back with
it bouncing back behind the goal for the Lin C
of a per scores David perra power play goal and
Detroit leads by two bu going to go around the
boards again larin's going to keep this puck in
and then just a short little play to pan takes
it off his left skate he has an option on the
back door as well for to Bret as he's sliding
down he's able to just beat Corp pasalo short side
he elevates it a Rolling Puck very quickly puts it
underneath the bar Sanderson on it Tero Rick wi
for Str working in shoot got a piece of that as
cider here's cider back across the
gos is there shoot that was blocked by
Sanderson here's the braket
back for Sider BS great pass W
scores and the Detroit power play strikes
again and makes it four to one this is all
about Puck Movement Detroit moves the puck so
well the initial block by Sanderson that stung
him but then they change sides for on off
the boards back to the top of the umbrella
and then it's just quick Puck movement maret's
going to slide it into that middle area turn
and [Applause] fire so Greg takes a spot here
of kachuck on the power play here's in shoots
at the goal post Dan right off the draw Josh
Norris is going to win it back run a little
bit of a pick and then as bson tries to go
short side just elevated right above the the
Blocker in the shoulder it took some negotiating
though it did happen right away in com ches back
in front what save BYO rebound and Terra was
blocked there by CER about to save the goal
he did he Dove across it it hit his left
skate as terce ankle tried to elevate it
now sta turns it over to spraw in
come Daniel spraw works it back shoot
scores scz is going to turn it over just
inside the or just outside the offensive
zone Blue Line sprung looking for options pops it
through the seam and bleno is going to finish it
off you see the reaction from the Superstar
c banks it down back to teraso being shoted
there by comfort and chman lays it ah head to
[Applause] Joseph in comes Greg his man falls
Greg in shoots [Applause] SC sh fell GRE takes
advantage start the season we talked about his
versatility here's a nice pass shot's going to
fall down a little pop play to Greg to himself
skates in tries to go block her sideo gets a
good chunk of it but not enough as it drops
down and slides into the net back around the
fishing that goes off the skate of Shar Jan y
poo centers it and de Bret all alone in front
puts the rebound wide to Bret two great looks
but can't score against his former team quick
Puck movement thereis Seno shoot pad sa who a
rebound Loos it from Greg roll that line Greg
back for Shaban he fires that's blocked by
cop lead pass the sprung busting in sprung with a
Chance cor settle the save and
the rebound knocked away from
Char and red rings going to leave
Auto walk be decisive 52 win